welcome to waters world I'm Jesse waters
the facts about Nathan Phillips that's
the subject of tonight's waters words by
now everybody's heard the story of the
Covington boys and by the way in a
minute we're gonna have an exclusive
sit-down with one of the members of the
community that started the whole thing
the black Hebrew Israelites but the
media has turned a blind eye to the
Native American activists his hatred his
lies and his background are gonna be
examined right now Phillips first told
The Washington Post and other outlets
that he was surrounded in harassed by
the Covington boys he told the Detroit
Free Press the boys were quote attacking
these four black individuals
he continued quote these young men were
beastly and these old black individuals
was their prey Phillips called it racism
and the quote hatred in their faces
resembled quote lynchings that were done
in America he added that the students
were chanting build the wall and once
the complete video was released
everything Phillips said turned out to
be a lie it was Phillips who approached
the boys and banged his drum in their
face nobody was about to attack the
black activists and nobody was chanting
build the wall Phillips was never trying
to defuse the situation as he claimed it
actually looks like Phillips and his
crew were the aggressors with the
students
after the confrontation with the boys
what did Phillips do he attempted to
disrupt Mass at Washington DC's National
Shrine philipson about 20 demonstrators
tried to force themselves into evening
mass bang their drums and totally
disrupt the service security called the
situation quote tense and had to
blockade Phillips and his crew from
disturbing the congregation Phillips has
a history of racially charged
confrontations four years ago the Native
Americans hold a very similar story
claiming that white students in Michigan
disrespected him and threw a beer can at
him
Phillips went to the police but no
evidence turned up to support his claim
Phillips has a rap sheet which includes
assault charges alcohol-related charges
and negligent driving charges he even
escaped from jail in Nebraska there's
been a lot of confusion over Nathan
Phillips military service in the Vietnam
era now I respect his service but his
dishonesty created that confusion
Phillips claimed he served in Vietnam
and was the victim of ugly protests upon
returning I'm a Vietnam vet and I served
in marine corps 72 to 76
I got honorable discharge and one of the
boxes in there they talk it shows up he
was a peacetime or what my box says is
that I was in theater I don't talk much
about my Vietnam times when I come home
those times I got spit on actually call
it a baby killer now here are the facts
the Marines say Phillips was a reservist
from 1972 to 1976 worked on
refrigerators stateside never deployed
and never served in Vietnam now there
are other reports that say Phillips went
AWOL several times but we haven't been
able to confirm those NBC News asked him
to clarify his service record what I've
always said is I've never stepped foot
in South Vietnam and that's I don't know
how clear how much clearer can that be
he could have been a lot clearer there
Nathan there's a phrase for that - it's
called Stolen Valor Nathan Phillips is a
lying provocateur with a victimization
fetish yet he was the source for all of
these mainstream media outlets who
bought his narrative without asking any
questions and used it to smear innocent
high-school students imagine all the
other shady sources the media has used
to attack innocent conservatives with
fake news